Welcome back everyone this will be my full
ms marvel episode 6 finale video there were a
bunch of easter eggs and references to everything
that's happening in marvel phase 4 right now and a
bunch of big reveals so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel marvel comic con
is also happening next week they're going to be
releasing a bunch of big trailers of course i'll
do videos for everything like the black panther 2
trailer is probably going to be their big reveal
we'll also probably get a preview for the
captain marvel 2 the marvels movie which
is where ms marvel is going to appear next
maybe for ant-man 3 quantum mania as well
because that's coming out in february next
year careful for spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet because there is
a bunch of x-men stuff that we have to talk
about too like they literally play the x-men
the animated series theme song during the
episode to let you know that she is basically
the next new mutant inside the mcu mild shot
which is probably the biggest surprise of
the episode like you kind of know where the
ms marvel character is going if you've read any
of her in the comics or even have a broad idea
about the character the big twist is making her
a mutant inside the mcu and speaking of mutants
x-men stuff they are doing a revival series for
x-men the animated series like they are doing
more episodes they're bringing a preview for
that probably a trailer or something like that
to comic con next week i'll do a video for that
too there are a couple big disney plus marvel
series that are gonna have trailers next week too
but mostly people are just thinking about all the
marvel movie trailers it's just a coincidence
that they make the big ms marvel x-men reveal
this week and then next week we also get a brand
new x-men trailer of some kind but we'll just
start at the beginning of the episode work our
way through shot by shot talking about easter eggs
wtf moments the x-men of it all starting with
the episode title no normal which is meant to
be a reference to kamala khan's message to komron
when she's talking him off the metaphorical ledge
so that he doesn't turn into a full-blown villain
inside the mcu and just for reference because she
is also a mutant in the mcu now that would make
him one too because he's basically the exact same
as her and just for reference i don't think this
will be the only way that they explain mutants
inside the mcu the term mutant is a little bit
different from the term x-men traditionally you
would consider mutants to be characters who are
born with their powers and born with the x-gene
that's why i think they specifically play the
x-men the animated series theme song instead of
just calling her a mutant and leaving it at that
like if they didn't want you to think about x-men
they wouldn't have played the x-men theme song
the whole message that she gives to comrade about
being a good person is also meant to be a callback
to the message that the sheik gave her about what
it really does mean to be a good person in this
life the actual opening scene is of damage control
investigating the destruction of bruno shop r.i.p
to the circle q after the death of kamran's mother
after she recants after she kind of redeems
herself a little bit sacrificing herself to
save the mcu damage control becomes the biggest
villain in the series if you really want to get
technical and point the finger it'd actually
be agent deeper who you'd blame for all this
she'd be the one to take the l for damage control
they kind of make the damage control agents seem
incompetent during this episode they're kind of
like the worst version of stormtroopers that you
see all the jokes about from star wars movies but
that's mostly because they were using non-lethal
rounds and they didn't actually want to kill
any of the kids like they wanted to take them in
without hurting anyone it's not really until the
end of the episode when things really go off the
rails when they start using live rounds against
them if they'd started doing that this would have
been a very short episode but if it wasn't clear
all this tech the damage control is using is based
on stark tech like they have the star-tech drones
that iron man created and all those pulse weapons
that they're using would be based on stark tech as
well i'm sure whichever version of the afterlife
that iron man went to because he is kind of
an atheist whichever alternate dimension he's
rolling in that metaphorical grave watching all
this happen when bruno and camron are escaping
on the subway it seems like there's also hindi
characters written on the windows and graffiti
if you think you know what that says write that
below in the comments there's also an ad right
next to them that they pass by that says u1
which foreshadows the ending of the episode
because they kind of wind up winning at the end
of the episode they all kind of get what they want
comron goes through a speed run version of what
ms marvel went losing control of his powers while
he's trying to figure out exactly what went on you
do hear his mother's voice calling to him from his
powers when they go crazy but i think that's
because of the genetic connection that they're
trying to draw to his mother like his mother's
remaining life force like whatever remnant of her
was left activated his powers so literally like
a piece of her is alive in him but it's kind of
like this echo after effect they play what sounds
like a hindi pop song under the marvel studios
intro scene and they actually just had a brand new
marvel title sequence in thor love and thunder the
newest one in thor love and thunder also includes
a version of ms marvel wearing her first comic
book accurate costume but she will get a second
one in the marvel's movie like another brand
new costume that's also to let you know that the
events of thor love and thunder take place after
the events of the ms marvel series it's meant
to be like the furthest forward we've been in
the marvel phase four movie timeline so far this
is all happening after spider-man no way home and
after doctor strange multiverse of madness they
have that funny scene where kamala tries to tell
the rest of her family the truth about the powers
and they just play it for a joke kind of like the
friends tv series where everybody already knows
the secret like oh this is brand new information
i'm learning this for the first time i can't
believe this it's also meant to be a reference
back to all the jokes about the father and the
technology that bruno upgraded for him which
they also use later when they're fighting damage
control at the school trying to distract everyone
with the speakers she calls herself nightlight
again they call her nightlight a couple times
in the episode to set up the end of the episode
where they eventually reveal the ms marvel name
which is also a big twist too the way that they
explain why she's called ms marvel but the whole
nightlight joke is meant to be a callback to the
spider-man night monkey joke when her brother and
sister-in-law ask all those technical questions
about how her powers work since the power comes
from inside her now the way they explain like
the newer power the bengal isn't technically
necessary it just enhances her abilities like the
bengal itself does have special powers but the way
they've treated it so far it's kind of like thor's
hammer mjolnir where it enhances her abilities it
has its own powers but like thor for instance
doesn't need mjolnir to use his regular powers
so she can run out of power theoretically if she
were to expend too much effort and pass out but
technically her ability is meant to be limitless
it's just that when she passes out she produces
way less of the energy because she is passed out
the way her family reacts is kind of like the way
the aunt may reacts to spider-man revealing his
powers like concerned about their safety but aunt
may for instance is generally supportive so is
her family just like in previous episodes they
have a bunch of custom versions of the ms marvel
comic book logo for the title sequence cycling
through all meant to be references to things that
happened during the episode like the yellow tape
for damage controls yellow tape the blueprints
are meant to represent the plans to create her
new comic book costume that her mother actually
had custom-made when they were back in pakistan
this one is based on her avengers fan films the
captain marvel fighting the shitauri also meant
to foreshadow the captain marvel cameo scene
in the post-credits scene don't worry i'll
explain what happened during that later in the
video because it's basically ms marvel trading
places like teleporting with the actual captain
marvel using the power of the bengal the way that
it teleported her back in time like a different
version of that teleporting them through space
instead of time there's the version of the high
school jersey sweatshirt logo meant to foreshadow
damage control attacking them at the school the
established 2014 is meant to be a reference to
kamala khan ms marvel number one in the comics
the beginning of her solo comic book series
she was created by g willow wilson the comic book
creator actually has a cameo scene at the end
of the episode when they're doing all the video
broadcasts of everyone that was there at the tack
like this is the actual comic book creator
of the kamala khan ms marvel character
technically her first appearance was in august
2013 in captain marvel number 14. the neon sign
is for the circle q rip because it just got blown
up by damage control the yellow one is for the
school bus because damage control coming to the
school the cast with the drawings the messages to
get well soon i think is for bruno's or someone
else's injury during the episode the old timey
digital one is actually an easter egg for captain
marvel's souped-up space pager that we saw in the
avengers infinity war post credit scene that nick
fury pulled out meant to also foreshadow her cameo
scene at the end of the episode the police car
one is for the end of the episode as well when the
cops actually wind up helping kamala khan against
the damage control agents the one with the airport
arrivals and departures is representing her coming
back from karachi because one of them literally
says karachi on it this one is based on all of ms
marvel's doodles of them having fun times together
at the celebration that the sheik holds after they
beat damage control at the end of the episode then
this one was based on all the drawings that came
from her imagination when they were walking and
talking about what to call her and what to
base her powers on like all the mashups and
combinations of captain marvel with other avengers
characters like this was the princess version of
captain marvel this was a version of captain
marvel and doctor strange captain strange this
one was black panther and captain marvel captain
panther there actually is a crossover between
those characters in the ultimate comics too even
though obviously chadwick boseman passed away
hopefully they'll find some way to do a version of
the ultimates like they'll introduce blue marvel
and some of the other characters for that then
the last one is just an explosion of her newer
energy referencing the way she uses her powers
in a bigger way during the ending of the episode
they show you all the captain marvel fair all over
her bedroom it's all meant to be comic book panels
like actual comic book panels of captain marvel
herself and also artwork of the captain marvel
movie like actual posters from the movie just to
foreshadow her cameo scene in the post-credits
scene like oh yes she is a big captain marvel
stan there's a lot of avengers fare around here
but we're also having a big cameo scene at the
end here they revealed that her mother had her
comic book accurate costume made for her while
they were still in karachi on the dl there must
have been a short time jump too where she had time
to actually have it made that's why it's in the
toffee box that her grandmother had been keeping
for the mother all those years like oh i kept them
around in case you ever came back she incorporated
red dagger's red scarf that he just gave to her
she bases her symbol on the arabic version of her
name from her broken necklace that she always wore
and this has obviously always been the ms marvel
logo so i think this is them basically trying to
create a bigger backstory for why her logo looked
like this the way that they also reveal her using
the ms marvel name is also a bit of a change from
the comics but they try to give it a little bit
more meaning like they actually say that her real
name kamala is based on marvel so it's almost like
her real name is ms marvel like it's not a fake
made up name inspired by captain marvel although
she is a captain marvel stan like her father says
her name kamala is based on kamal which translates
to marvel so she is literally ms marvel she's
also using the mask that bruno gave to her as
a gift and the blue in her uniform is made from
the blue cloth that the other leader of the red
daggers gave to her so the whole costume is just
meant to incorporate all these different items
that have been really personal to her when they
revealed her costume she's also sitting underneath
the captain marvel poster that's actually based on
a comic book panel in real life like it's actually
from the comics they have the funny montage where
they're hopping across the traffic in the air
trying to help comrade and then stopping for the
red light because they want to show that she's a
really good person sort of foreshadowing the
end making damage control seem even more like
the villains like she's willing to follow the
letter of the law but damage control is not that
was also what they were trying to go for with the
whole vibe at the mosque where bruno takes comrade
to try and seek some sanctuary in damage control
steam rolling through a lot of those regulations
what the sheik says to kamron as they leave
is also meant to inspire him along with kamala
khan's help at the end of the episode so that
he doesn't wind up completely destroying this
entire mcu reality theoretically if he got off
the rails the whole idea is that he would have
opened up another portal through the veil and
the clandestine dimension would have eventually
absorbed the regular mcu dimension like what
almost wound up happening in last week's episode
the whole thing with zoe already being there
and running up trying to help because she
was trying to get better posts because the
lighting in the theater room is them kind of
bending over backwards like a lot of the way
that this comes together is very convenient
the way they play her in the series is a bit like
her comic book arc like she starts out being kind
of a mean girl but then she winds up becoming good
friends with kamala and there's this big story in
the comics about her coming out which they kind
of reference in the episode like when she talks
about kamala revealing her truth to the world
on her own time that's meant to be a reference
to zoe in the comics coming out she does another
version of her planning montage with the drawings
on the board like she goes full charlie day meme
drawing on the board just like she did when she
was trying to get into avengers con then a lot of
this montage is meant to be very reminiscent of
the spider-man films and then going full science
bros like it's kind of like spiderman no way home
with the chemistry scenes except obviously
the stakes here are very very ground level
by comparison like the whole energy here with
the finale is supposed to be more like what was
happening during hawkeye and during spider-man
homecoming also because they just released thor
love and thunder the whole whiteboard sequence is
similar to the thor loving thunder scene of meek
basically drawing the entire plot of the movie on
the board they set up the whole runner with what
happened to comrade's mother and him learning
the secret to try and push him over the edge
of the end of the episode like early on bruno is
like please don't tell him this is like the worst
possible time to tell him something like that as i
kind of explain like he starts to go off the rails
theoretically if he got even worse like if he
went even crazier he'd open another portal to the
clandestine dimension and the exact same problem
that happened in karachi would happen again here
zoe uses her social media accounts to get the rest
of the public in the area to show up outing damage
control's actions to the public it's sort of like
them pulling a reverse j jonah jameson daily bugle
on them like in the spider-man movie spider-man
far from home spider-man no way home they use j
jonah jameson's broadcast and mysterio's video
with the whole world learning about it to turn
on spider-man this time they do the reverse
and it's all truthful stuff because all stuff
is actually being done by damage control revealing
it to the world when they have some of the brave
scenes of kamala khan versus kamran she uses
some of her comic book abilities but obviously
in the way that they've explained with her newer
abilities like she embiggens herself she literally
actually uses the word mbigen later in the episode
too and if we're talking about x-men easter eggs
here because there's so many x-men easter eggs
towards the end of the episode when komron exits
the building to all the damage control agents
and the guns they fire on him it's just like
the classic x-men scene of magneto stopping all
the bullets except this time it's kamala khan
stopping all the bullets with her newer shield
they also use this scene to show you more about
how her powers work during battles like this
like they're not invincible shields like the
constructs she creates are meant to be invincible
it's kind of like green lantern rules they're all
based on her willpower so like the stronger the
more focused she is the stronger her abilities are
but like you can hurt them with sonic damage with
physical damage with energy damage they give her
her own version of a get up spider-man scene like
the spider-man homecoming scene where he's almost
down for the count and then has to rally the
whole arc here with komron coming back from the
edge of darkness her talking him down was kind of
predictable it's kind of like a speed run version
of his character arc like wait a minute i'm so
pissed off about my mom but now i'm not pissed off
they explain that he escapes through the sewer
system back to karachi with the help of the red
daggers and per the end of the episode it sounds
like he's just gonna eventually start helping them
agent cleary who's the supervisor damage control
from spider-man no way home makes agent dever take
the l for the episode they have the montage of
all the locals who were there posting videos about
what happened and like i said they do have the
comic book creator of the kamala khan character
g willow wilson during this scene they even have
her weird school counselor making a video too
even the sheik from the moss post a funny hot dog
video hopefully this hot dog is halal this little
kid is also the same little kid that she saved
at the mosque in that video a couple episodes ago
presumably he also gave nakia back her expensive
shoes because he was revealed as the mystery shoe
thief at the mosque then when she's eyeballing
herself in the mirror kind of being proud of the
way that she looks they also have a captain marvel
poster from the movie nearby just to foreshadow
the end of the episode with the post-credits scene
bruno wearing the caltech hoodie foreshadows him
going to caltech the note that he leaves is for
kamala khan telling him about his choice to go
presumably if they do a season two he will be back
and i think that they will probably wind up doing
some kind of season two then they have the scene
with her father basically giving her the ms marvel
name effectively are kind of explaining why she's
ms marvel she's the one that kind of connects the
dots but he's the person who literally says the
name out loud first like he is the first person
in the series that says the name ms marvel and
like i said it's all based on her real name like
kamala is meant to translate from arabic to marvel
so she is literally ms marvel without having to
ever connect herself to captain marvel but she
is a captain marvel stan so it all just kind of
works out in a really nice way the ending scene
of her sitting on the street light looking out
across the water at the new york city landscape is
right out of the comics and they have the custom
newer energy based time jump transition with bruno
trying to borrow comrade's car and like i said he
basically reveals that she is a mutant in the
mcu when he starts talking about her genes he
literally says the word mutation and they play
the actual x-men the animated series theme song
they listed in the credits specifically too so
even though they've kind of been back and forth
about the way that scarlet witch is a mutant
in the mcu like billy and tommy are mutants
in the mcu from one division this is like the
first time that they've literally actually said
someone in the mcu is a mutant like he uses the
word mutation in a way that you haven't heard in
the mcu in previous movies so just to be clear
she's not an inhuman she is a mutant she's much
closer to the x-men mythology with the x gene
like i said though i don't think this would be
the only way that they explain mutants in the mcu
because it's not like she's going to suddenly have
like a thousand different kids herself because
they just included all the x-men easter eggs and
doctor strange too the multiverse is such a big
idea that's just another way that they're going
to explain mutants in the mcu like deadpool is
going to come into the mcu eventually but it's
going to be the ryan reynolds version from those
original fox films so another multiverse explainer
i'm sure they're going to be a thousand questions
about this going into comic con next week but
thankfully we do have comic con next week and we
will get some answers about all this and how it
all fits together of course i'll be doing videos
for all that stuff when it drops but then after
they play the x-men the animated series theme
song they also make an avengers post credit scene
reference to the shawarma saying they're going to
get shawarma and i think because they mentioned
shawarma a couple times during the ms marvel
episodes i think this is the first series that's
referenced that avengers post credit scene in
such a big way then the actual credits are meant
to be a combination of the karachi and credit
scenes and the regular jersey city ones from
the previous episodes which are just a combination
of different comic book art like all the drawings
that you see are literal comic book panels taken
out of the ms marvel comic book they also bring
back the hawkeye tracksuit mafia easter egg with
a tracksuit bros van in jersey city so kingpin is
out there watch out for him but then during the
actual post-credits scene you see her looking at
her bangle and it starts to go off while she's
thinking about carol danvers captain marvel and
the bengal in combination with her powers kind of
does the same thing that it did when it sent her
into the past previously except this time it
teleports her and captain marvel across space
instead of across time with them kind of swapping
spots so like this is actual carol danvers captain
marvel now in this young girl's bedroom not having
any idea where she is or why she's in this girl's
bedroom she doesn't know anything that happened
during the events of the series about kamala khan
herself or the alternate clandestine dimension so
like she's freaking out here like what is going
on and you have to imagine that somewhere else
either on nick fury's space station or wherever
captain marvel was like increased scroll space
on the other side of the universe kamala khan
is also freaking out going wait a minute what's
going on here where are these aliens where am i
but the way they play it kamala khan wasn't
trying to use her powers or wasn't actively
trying to do anything with the bangle like this
happened because of something that the bengal
wanted to happen and that she was subconsciously
thinking about obviously meant to be a teaser for
the marvels movie because right after this they
have a stinger scene where it says ms marvel will
return during the marvels we might get a preview
or some kind of teaser for that during comic con
next week in marvel's big panel but i think the
big main attraction is going to be the black
panther 2 trailer because like that's the next
big marvel movie and then ant-man 3 quantomania
with king the conqueror will be the next movie
after that in february whatever they wind up
releasing of course i'll do a video for it the
marvel's movie isn't coming out till november
next year in 2023 so it's gonna be a while but
if you spotted any big easter eggs or references
during the episode that it didn't talk about in
the video just write them below in the comments
or if you have big questions about her being a
mutant or the way they're explaining this i do
have a bunch of comic con videos planned for the
next week or so i'll try to do as much stuff as
possible because there's going to be a lot of big
stuff that they'll reveal a lot of big trailers
while you wait for everything everyone click
here for all my thor love and thunder alternate
ending and deleted scenes and click here for my
brand new loki season 2 first look teaser and
breakdown thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!